well joining me now in the studio is
former raf pilot and now advisor at
universal defense and security solutions
air vice marshal sean bell uh sean good
to see you again and so
let's just have a look at the map that
we're now becoming so familiar with and
we've seen that the battle for kiev
appears to be over we've seen that the
russian troops pulling back what of what
they've left behind
yes they've
clearly withdrawn and they've had a bit
of a bloody nose there and as they
withdraw and obviously press and
everybody is able to get in and see some
of the carnage at butcher i think the
the horrific scenes we're seeing pipes
into our living room are really just a
clear impression of what war is like
wars are brutal and wars of national
survival which ukraine is currently
involved in are particularly brutal we
haven't seen this sort of thing since
the second world war the veterans of the
second world war there are fused alive
it's a great privilege to to meet some
of them on a regular basis um most of
them will not even talk about their that
what happens in these wars because the
images are so graphic and horrendous one
who did talk very eloquently um was
harry billing who was involved in d-day
and he described very graphically how
the sea was running red with the blood
of his his colleagues uh tragically he
passed away uh this past week and
apparently in his final few words were
love one another what a poignant
reflection from an amazing man
absolutely
um
so back to this conflict and of course
the russians moving away from kiev but
they do appear to be regrouping
what are you going to expect to see in
the coming weeks and days do you think
in this particular area to the east well
it's a consistent question isn't it
where are putin's ambitions now it looks
like his initial plan to take the whole
of ukraine has failed but what is his
plan plan b um mod briefings and experts
seem to reinforce the view that he's
likely to focus in the east uh some of
the troops are um amassing it at bella
belgarrod up to the north of kharkiv
there and we're fully expecting that
he'll redeploy troops from kiev and also
from russia and focus on um on on the
donbass why the donbass i think there's
three main reasons for the donbass
russia has invested over the last 10
years in an insurgency there and will be
keen to bring that to conclusion
secondly of course the lines all the
supply lines are much easier to bring
things in from russia whether it's
troops fuel weaponry material if you
remember the 40-mile convoy of logistics
that was stuck you won't have that
problem there and likewise um air power
we've really not seen russian air power
much involved
over ukraine
and that's largely because ukraine has
been quite successful is shooting them
out of the sky i suspect that near the
russian border they'll be a lot more
confident we'll see russian air power
much more involved and of course down in
mariopol fighting will continue it's
looking amazing defense by the
ukrainians but it's difficult to see
it's looking pretty bleak down there and
now of course president putin originally
wanted to take
the whole of ukraine we believe this
certainly seems like a more modest
ambition what would you say was the
motivation for this apparent change of
attack again really difficult inside
putin's mind but it looks like if he
still aspires to take the whole of
ukraine this conflict will go on for
years rather than weeks or months what
looks more likely is that he'll focus
his ambitions and then
be ready to negotiate out to the west in
odessa probably still
an ambition of his but probably not
realizable in the near term um but let's
not be let's be quite clear the the
russians are ten times the size
militarily if they focus their efforts
on a small field of land um that will
make life very difficult for ukrainian
forces i think we've yet to see the full
might of russia uh deployed in this
battle and until putin's revised
objectives are met we're not going to
see any meaningful negotiations anytime
soon okay sean bell thanks very much